- Steak, that's what a man eats.
- Made from stuff guys need.
- Eat like a man, man.
- There's no one that can
relate to that better than I do
because I've lived in that world.
Steak is for men.
- Go meat.
- They show this commercials, burgers,
George Foreman with the grill.
- Yeah.
- And the big sandwiches
and all that stuff.
- Eat like a man and be full like a man.
- This is great, great
marketing by the meat industry.
- Serious man food.
- Selling that idea
that real men eat meat.
- You will look like more of a man
with a quarter pounder in your hand.
- But you got to understand
that's marketing.
That's not based on reality.
- Okay, I'm going to take
you down to the exam room.
When I think of a manly
man I think if somebody
who has strength, endurance,
sexual prowess, and fertility.
In fact, what the scientific
studies are showing
is that the more meat men eat,
the more quickly they
lose their manly manhood.
- [Narrator] The blood test
with the Miami Dolphins
measured how a single meal
could affect blood flow
throughout the entire body.
I asked Dr. Spitz, if he
could conduct an experiment
with three collegiate athletes,
but this time on a more specific
part of the male anatomy.
- So there's a model of the penis.
- [Narrator] Dr Spitz is
the lead delegate of Urology
for the American Medical Association.
When it comes to the penis,
he literally wrote the book.
- Now you're going to be
putting this device on yourself.
One ring goes on the base of the penis,
and the other ring, goes
on at the tip of the penis
just behind the head of the penis.
It knows how tight to squeeze
to know when an erection's starting
because when it squeezes
it will determine.
Oh, it's now of a larger circumference,
something's happening.
What we're going to look at is
what effect the meal you have
has on your erections that night.
And You're going to be eating
two different kinds of meals.
For this study on the first night,
we gave the guys burritos that had meat.
Beef, chicken, pork, but
really high quality meats.
Grass fed, organic.
On the second night, we gave
them very similar burritos,
but we swapped out animal
portions for plant based protein.
- This is really good.
- I thought this was gonna
be nasty, not gonna lie.
- I didn't think we
were gonna eat a burrito
I thought we gonna eat a salad.
(laughs)
- This study is gonna take advantage
of a natural function that
occurs in men when they sleep.
Men's bodies create erections.
And this occurs throughout the night
while the subject is asleep.
Once an erection happens,
this device can sense it
and a printout is generated,
of how firm the erection was,
how long it lasted and how
many of them there were,
to see if we can see a
physical effect on erections,
as a result of what they
just ate for dinner.
This is where we take
a look at the results.
So Mason I'm gonna give
you your results first.
- Oh cool
- Why don't you to take those out.
- All right.
- Okay.
The bigger the circumference,
the harder the erection.
And so you'll notice
that, that first circle
which is the meat meal,
is not as big a circle,
it's not as hard an erection
as that second circle, vegan meal.
Now let's look at the second sheet.
The second sheet is accumulation
of how many erections
and for how long you had
over the course of the night.
So that first stubby graph,
(laughs)
Is really, it's not
the size of your penis.
- I'm struggling (laughs)
Is not the size your penis is
how many minutes throughout
the night you had erections.
- Wow.
- Blake, let's take a
look at your results.
- Oh no
(laughs)
- Hold composure.
- And look again, like
Mason, you were more erect
after the plant based diet
than the meat based diet.
Okay, how about how
often you had erections?
Wow.
(laughs)
That's almost a 500% difference.
- Damn man.
That's crazy.
- Blake, you ready for yours?
All right here you go.
You had about a 13% change in the hardness
of your erections.
Okay, let's look at how many or how long
you had erections for.
- Bro
(laughs)
- Show it.
- [Dr. Spitz] Yeah,
Don't hold out.
(laughs)
- Bro that's an hour, bro.
- So you guys all had
a very similar response
to the meat meal versus the plant meal.
- That's crazy.
Growing up and if I saw some big dude
at a restaurant eating a big old steak,
I was like, I need to be like that.
And then like I see like
a guy ordering a salad
off the menu, I'm like
- He's soft right?
- Yeah look at that guy, what's he doing?
But really the guy eating
the big steak, is soft
(laughs)
- So when you take your
date out on Valentine's day,
where are you going to take them to eat?
- To the veggie grills.
(laughs)
- Okay, Veggie grill.
- Now, this is not a
scientifically validated study,
but the results that we're
seeing are very exciting.
I think this is going to
wake a lot of people up.
I think it's going to wake
up people who have penises,
and I think it's a wake up people
who like people who have penises.